vont en 2020 votre maman lou euh cette
maison et par vivre avec vous chez son
compagnon malheureusement le locataire
cesse de payer ses loyers et votre maman
est gravement malade exactement donc
elle a tout fait pour essayer de le
faire partir oui c'est ça là avait
commencé les procédures quelques mois
après après qu'il a arrêté de payer les
loyers et puis et moi j'ai repris en
fait le procédures sont des séries en
février alors vivez un enfer
c'était quoi les solutions à ce
moment-là les solutions en fait on est
passé ma mère était passée avec le
huissier donc commandement de payer de
quitter les lieux etc on a suivi
vraiment toutes les procédures et puis
le jugement a été rendu le 16 juin à la
suite de ça on lui a accordé deux mois
pour quitter les lieux donc le jugement
était vraiment ma faveur remboursement
de la dette expulsion on lui accorder
encore deux mois pour quitter les lieux
il n'est pas parti le huissier est venu
constater et puis et puis la dernière
procédure était l'expulsion avec l'aide
de la force publique que la sous-préfète
a refusé en fait avant pas très hivernal
c'est ça malheureusement votre maman
décède de sa maladie ce jour-là vous
héritez de cette maison et forcément du
squatteur
vous êtes alors promis de le faire
partir oui exactement en fait ma mère
c'est vraiment battu pour cette maison
je suis d'une famille modeste ma mère a
travaillé toute sa vie pour payer cette
maison elle était malade en plus elle
s'est battue sur son lit de l'hôpital
elle avait un cancer pour écouter pour
les mettre dehors et aujourd'hui c'est
pour ça que je veux vraiment pas laisser
tomber l'affaire et c'est pour ça aussi
que j'ai pas assez toute la semaine
dernière devant la maison j'étais en
congé j'ai passé toute ma semaine devant
la maison on va revenir sur votre action
puisque au départ vous pensez que ce
serait facile et un moment vous êtes
rendu compte que ça allait être un enfer
exactement alors moi je pensais que la
justice allait elle est le maître dehors
avant la trêve hivernale j'avais envoyé
une lettre sous préfet j'avais tout bien
fait et puis la sous-préfaite a donc
refusé quelques jours avant la trêve
c'est un changement de Sous Préfet
justement et puis je me suis retrouvé le
bec dans l'eau entre guillemets pourquoi
la Sous Préfet refuse que c'est quoi ces
mots ces motifs alors juste avant il y
avait un sous-préfet j'avais contacté ce
monsieur et il y a eu un changement de
ce préfet justement pendant quelques
jours avant la trêve hivernale et elle
me dit qu'elle n'a pas pu prendre une
décision elle ne vous elle ne voulait
pas pardon mettre de la précarité sur la
précarités
donc finalement après un long combat un
jugement été rendu le 16 juin dernier
ordonnant l'expulsion et le
remboursement de la dette c'était il y a
4 mois et demi exactement donc là vous
dites ça y est c'est une victoire
exactement moi de juin je me dis la
trêve hivernale est le 1er novembre ça
nous laisse largement le temps pour le
mettre dehors et au final aujourd'hui il
est dans la maison et moi je suis dehors
donc il s'est rien passé depuis rien du
tout des procédures des appels
téléphoniques tout le temps et puis et
rien il est dans la maison il sait qu'il
a pas été expulsé juste après le
jugement parce qu'on lui laisse après le
jugement encore deux mois en fait pour
retrouver un logement et puis il n'a pas
voulu partir donc on laisse encore des
délais des délais et puis au final rien
ne bouge depuis ça fait 15 mois qu'il
paye plus le loyer 15 mois ça fait
combien ça 11 500 euros de dette 11500
euros de dettes vous allez voir ce qui
vous répond dans un instant parce qu'on
l'a eu au téléphone
le squatteur entre guillemets le pire
c'est que depuis mardi le 1er novembre
comme vous l'avez dit le squatteur ne
peut plus du tout être expulsé car la
trêve hivernale a débuté
quand vous comparez sa situation à la
vôtre ça vous rend folle ce que vous
êtes où vous alors moi je suis hébergé
par des proches en région lilloise j'ai
de la chance d'avoir des proches mais je
me dis quelqu'un de mon âge qui n'a
personne il est dehors voilà donc elle
est hébergée par des profs pendant que
l'autre est dans sa maison c'est non
mais je vous dis énorme à justice encore
à vos yeux vous devez vous dire si bien
sûr ça me rend un petit peu folle parce
que je comprends pas j'avais fait
vraiment des lettres à la
sous-préfecture en expliquant ma
situation en demandant l'expulsion avant
la trêve et puis au final aujourd'hui
moi je suis dehors jusqu'au 1er avril et
lui ne paye pas et en plus il s'en fout
complètement et qu'est-ce qui vous dit à
vous parce que vous allez entendre ce
qu'il dit là alors moi il avait dit au
tribunal qu'il ne payait plus le loyer
parce que ma mère ne venait plus
chercher les loyers sauf que ma mère
était malade elle est décédée donc de
mauvaise foi et puis il m'a clairement
dit que la justice était de son côté et
qu'il partirait pas avant le 1er avril
de toute façon il a été menaçant parfois
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit oui quand j'étais
j'ai passé la semaine justement là-bas
il est rentré un soir
parce que vous avez passé vous avez
décidé de mener un combat contre cette
situation cauchemardesque et cette
injustice vous avez notamment collé de
nombreuses banderoles devant la maison
regardez ça je trouve que c'est très
fort ce que vous avez fait moi regardez
regardez ce que vous avez fait regardez
voilà squatteur c'est lui là oui c'est
lui là d'accord voilà donc c'est mis ça
voilà
donc vous avez mis ça dans sa maison dès
11500 €. où est la justice voilà donc
vous êtes obligé de vous faire justice
vous-même squatteur c'est qui le
monsieur qui filme c'est moi qui filme
du village d'accord très bien et
qu'est-ce qui vous a dit là quand vous
avez fait ça il m'a dit tu vires tes
merdes et puis tu arrêtes de m'emmerder
avec tes conneries un truc du genre il
fait quoi dans la vie ce monsieur ah il
travaille en intérim en plus c'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours travaillé et
qui ne paye pas
d'accord il paye pas il vit tout seul
dans la maison tout seul oui
votre objectif c'était de médiatiser
votre avenir votre affaire lui ça lui
fait ni chaud ni froid ou bien
on le voit sur cette vidéo ça l'énerve
un petit peu mais j'ai pas l'impression
que ça change quelque chose alors vous
allez entendre qui vous dit parce qu'on
l'a eu au téléphone il explique à ses
yeux il n'est pas un squatteur et que
s'il ne paye pas son loyer c'est limite
de votre faute écouter
comme ça du jour au lendemain
et puis bon après je suis
jusqu'au je suis pas son tribunal comme
quoi il était décédé
je sais même pas quoi répondre parce que
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire rien
il dit voilà bah forcément il avait pas
de nouvelles de votre maman
vous savez que ma mère était malade
qu'elle avait un cancer et au tribunal
il a dit devant madame la juge que il
était au courant en plus mais je sais
j'ai même pas de de mots en fait c'est
juste de la mauvaise foi et puis
s'il n'est pas parti c'est pour une
raison claire il n'a pas d'autre
logement pour le moment regardez ce
qu'il dit
[Musique]
non
et si on vous propose un relogement vous
accepterez
la loi élan depuis cette année c'est
vrai les squatteurs si on leur propose
la loi sur le très lente c'est pas la
loi non mais la loi et on leur propose
c'est nouveau alors propose durant la
trêve hivernale j'entends bien parce que
on y est dedans là alors propose un
nouveau logement ils ne peuvent pas le
refuser donc là il dégagerait mais
arrêtez les conneries il travaille il
est tout seul il fait de l'intérêt il
peut pas se démerder pour aller chercher
un appartement il y a des agences
de rentrer dans un pavillon demain avec
une piscine j'en ai marre de ma maison
de merde
il a de la porte de la force pour
détacher les trucs c'est un gaillard et
le mec il veut qu'on le relâche il veut
qu'on le relâche où en fait [ __ ] merde
tu travailles tu en intérim bouge-toi le
cul va chercher un appartement tout seul
il faut comment les gens Tom marche sur
la tête les mecs là réveillez-vous là
caribou on s'en [ __ ]
il habite gratuitement chez les gens
dommage
la seule chose que je te demande prends
pas ses affaires non non non
franchement Mégane le locataire s'en
prend aussi directement à vous Mégane
pour lui il n'a rien à vous dire car
vous êtes une menteuse
mes amis c'est des gens pas
fréquentables comme aller à le dire déjà
vu dans les connais pas à quel moment
elle a agressé ainsi de suite que
c'est pas grave c'est pour moi je suis
n'importe quoi
qu'est-ce que vous répondez quand il
vous racontez n'importe quoi mais c'est
je mens pas c'est quelqu'un qui a des
problèmes d'alcool il a fait une
interview pour la télé il les ai
complètement
ivre donc moi je vous dire le problème
d'alcool ou pas pour un d'alcool ce que
je vois c'est qu'il paye pas le loyer
voilà il doit 11500 €, le loyer il le
paye pas donc ça vous est monté par
là-dessus le loyer il la veille pas une
décision de justice mais moi j'ai envie
de dire que fait alors là Bernard
Montiel monsieur loi
là comment ça fait qu'il soit pas il est
pas été mis dehors tu as Gilles Verdez
c'est la peur de la sous-préfète je vous
le dis très franchement la nouvelle
sous-préfaite elle a eu peur parce
qu'elle avait le temps elle avait le
temps et Mégane quoi elle a eu peur de
quoi elle a eu peur de prendre une
décision elle a eu peur de mettre auquel
préfère la laisser dehors elle que lui
je ne légitime pas je dis elle a eu peur
et d'ailleurs elle a eu tellement peur
que l'État parce que vous avez suivi
toutes les procédures et l'État va sans
doute après vous indemniser ils vous ont
dit vous serez indemnisés parce que
l'État se rend compte que la décision
est
aberrant très bizarre d'accord donc du
coup c'est qu'il est donc lui il paye
pas 11000 et nous les français avec nos
impôts on va payer c'est qu'il est parce
que c'est pas l'état
français
n'existe pas l'état à chaque fois
j'entends des gens tous les jours oui
mais c'est pas grave c'est l'argent de
l'État on a qu'à demander à l'État mais
l'état c'est les gens les mecs c'est
l'état c'est pas un gouver c'est pas une
banque c'est l'autre qui paye pas moi je
vais pas payer moi non plus mais là mais
ça ça me tue les histoires comme ça mais
c'est incroyable
handicap il est normal ce mec là il
marche pas
écoutez écoutez ce qu'il va dire ensuite
il va encore plus loin puisqu'il
souhaiterait porter plainte bien sûr
tous les dégradations qui viennent faire
autrement ça par contre
[Musique]
toi
s'amuse
de changer ou nettoyer parce que
voilà
quand vous entendez ça
vraiment j'ai même pas les mots je sais
même pas quoi lui dire c'est c'est
stupide c'est écœurant et c'est
j'ai je sais pas Raymond
et non parce que je vais passer pour un
fou qui s'énerve mais c'est quand même
assez complètement dingue 15 mois c'est
ça 15 mois 15 mois qu'il est dans un
endroit qu'il n'a pas à être là c'est
pas un mois c'est pas deux mois il a pas
six enfants il est pas handicapé il est
pas dans une situation précaire alors ça
veut dire maintenant le message qu'on
envoie là la sous-préfetouite la
sous-préfaite elle a pas eu le courage
mais si tu as pas le courage ne soit pas
sous préfet tranquille
ne viens pas avec des trucs de
république des macarons sur ta voiture
je suis pressé
sous préfet c'est ça qu'on demande de
faire les choses pour la France on
demande de respecter les règles et
surtout de pas ouvrir des robinets pour
des gens qui vont dire ah bah parce que
moi tu sais ce que je me dis là mais
mais les gens allez squatter des maisons
on vous fait rien pourquoi vous y allez
pas allez-y il se passe
surtout après n'allait pas dans des
agences
pourquoi c'est pas un délit ça un moment
quand il y a une décision de justice
quand le mec reste dedans c'est un déni
je suis désolé situation
il y a une amende il a quoi c'est un
délire ah oui il risque il risque il
risque qu'on risque de 30000 euros
oui mais ce qui est insupportable avec
cette histoire de très bivernale c'est
que le postulat de départ c'est des
clichés sur les locataires et les
propriétaires qui sont complètement
déconnectés de la réalité ou sans autant
que tous les propriétaires c'est des
gens fortunés c'est ça pour qui ça
change rien de percevoir un loyer ou pas
à la fin du mois le meilleur exemple
c'est Mégane sa maman elle s'est battu
pour avoir le logement et aujourd'hui
c'est elle qui se retrouve dans la merde
c'est n'importe quoi il faut que ça
change évite c'est horrible faut pas y
toucher situation il y a des situations
il ne faut pas toucher à la traîner
c'est c'est sérieux là très grave mais
lui qu'est-ce qu'il a à voir avec la
tribulaire on le prévient au mois de
juin juin c'est toujours le même procédé
on en a on a l'impression qu'ils
insultent la justice il y a un huissier
qui vient moi c'est un huissier il vient
me voir tu vois faut que je me casse ça
chauffe l'huissier il vient il y a une
tribunal qui a donné une décision je me
casse je me démerde je vais chercher un
appart je me débrouille les mecs on a
l'impression qu'ils disent mais tu es
qui toi tu es un huissier mais je vais
venir je vais tenir jusqu'au mois
d'octobre et au mois d'octobre jusqu'au
à Marseille tous vous faire [ __ ] c'est
ça qui sont en train de dire bien sûr le
message qu'on ouvre le robinet qu'on
ouvre je me répète c'est qu'on dit aux
gens rentrer dans les maisons des gens
qui ont des résidences rentrer
installez-vous prenez des maisons avec
des piscines c'est toujours plus sympa
prenez des cuisines équipées avec des
cheminées et qui fait toute façon vous
avez le temps pas vous sortir et on en
revient toujours un truc qui serait
catastrophique et qui est en train
d'arriver et on a eu le on a eu
l'exemple encore deux semaines c'est que
les gens qui se font juste 6 semaines et
qui n'en peuvent plus et ça c'est et je
vais vous dire pourquoi on parle de ça
ici parce qu'on ne veut pas de ça on
veut pas que les gens se justifier mais
à un moment les mecs deviennent ouf là
je t'explique Mégane je te le dis ça
aurait été peut-être à un autre gars et
ça se serait mal passé je vous dis ce
serait mal passé et voilà et derrière
c'est le gars qui est qui c'est la
victime qui devient coupable mais là on
respecte n'a pas fait son travail
de la
il y a une décision de justice qui est
quand même complètement de la République
on doit avoir des couilles c'est tout
merci à ma raison entièrement raison
c'est vrai c'était l'admissible et
évidemment on peut pas vivre comme ça
mais la seule responsable de cette
histoire c'est la sous-préfaite mais on
l'a dit que ce soit clair oui que ce
soit très clair c'est elle qu'il faut
c'est la seule qui peut envoyer la force
pour moi le mec qui m'en fous Mégane
c'est quoi que maman est décédée il a
même pas de respect pour votre maman
et en plus il se connaissait étant jeune
c'est pour ça que ma mère lui a loué la
maison
c'est comme si quelqu'un qui avait
toujours travaillé qui allait travailler
en vélo ma mère a eu a voulu lui faire
plaisir en lui louant la maison
[Musique]
on va essayer de j'espère que cette
histoire va bouger pour vous on aura des
bonnes nouvelles bientôt merci merci
beaucoup